what was the offseason light for you
personally because it had been a long
time since you hadn't missed the
playoffs and I remember hearing someone
like Chris Bosh say one of your former
teammates say when you come back this
year you will come back with a vengeance
it was a great summer for me
got an opportunity to spend a lot of
time with my family my friends shot a
shot a movie Space Jam that I'm truly
excited about and will be great and also
got an opportunity to put in a lot of
work on my game so and take care of my
body be able to refresh my body reset my
body so it was a great summer for me it
was long something I haven't been
accustomed to over the last pass
previous years but you know you take
each day and I enjoyed each day that I
have LeBron I think the longest summer
since 2005 and you had been in a rhythm
probably going to the finals and getting
ready for a certain date how does that
impact your training in the offseason
and how do you feel physically just with
that switch and how long it's been I
don't think it impacted my training at
all because I train all year round
pretty much obviously I'll take a little
bit time after the season from
basketball just you know because we do
so much pounding and bumping and
grinding on on on a hardwood over there
but as far as training I train all year
round you know so in that instance it
didn't change much obviously I ramped it
up a lot more over the last couple
months you know from you know laid a you
know a protic difference between late
April and you know August and September
was obviously two training sessions and
the regiment was a little bit different
as far as ramping it up as far as
intensity but as far as me just training
I did that all summer LeBron
we've been kind of talking about this
but you've never really quite had a
summer like this given everything that
happened where you are in your career
and as long as you were off I mean you
had to sit and watch the playoffs and a
finals you haven't played basketball
since I think April mentally where are
you how did you come through this was it
a clarifying moment and refocused you
just where are you you made it sound so
bad like sitting and watching basketball
is such a bad thing I actually enjoyed
it I think you guys seen some of my
Instagram post when I was actually
showing you guys me watching the
playoffs I didn't miss one game by the
way throughout the whole postseason not
one I watched every single last one of
them even when I was on vacation I
watched him from a competitor stop
standpoint obviously you want to be out
there and I wanted to be out there with
me and my teammates but we didn't make
it so you take that as it is but for me
I'm just trying to refocus myself
refocus my mind in my body and you know
prepare myself throughout the summer on
you know what I wanted to do and me
individually Homma be a better player
but a better leader this year and it'd
be as great as I can be to help his
franchise do ultimately what he wants to
do and that's to be a better franchise
on the floor we want to be able to
compete every single night and obviously
we know what the long-term goal is but
it's all about the process of today I
was just wondering it was such a long
process for this team to finally acquire
Anthony Davis when that happened what
were you doing and how exciting was it
for you that it was finally done what
was I doing do not remember exactly what
I was doing but I can tell you that I
was ecstatic very excited I mean I know
the caliber of player 80 is not only
from a basketball standpoint but also
from a leadership standpoint and what he
can bring to any franchise and you know
when Rob and everyone in the upstairs
you know did what they had to do it to
acquire a talent and a person as a Dee
I was me obviously truly excited as you
guys probably see how much time we spent
together in the summertime so obviously
that spoke for itself but it's exciting
to have such a beautiful young mind a
beautiful player but also a great leader
as well you know and I don't think he
gets a lot of credit for that
being a leader that he is as well so I
think it's a great opportunity for this
franchise to have such a you know just
all around you know all-around person I
think the basketball will speak for
itself which is all-around great person
the Brian well what has been your
approach food to you with the way you
think your team should start a season
and what will it be this year especially
in the West being so tough I think our
approach is how we approach every day we
have to try to maximize each and every
day and it starts with you know you know
tomorrow you know our first day of
practice first day at training camp on
how we get better you know it's gonna be
a process for us we also know what what
our goal wants to become but you can't
shortcut the process and if we come in
every day learn from our coaches staff
learn from each other get to know one
another we have a new team we have a few
returning guys but we have a lot of guys
that wasn't a part of the team last year
so you know chemistry and camaraderie
and togetherness and how we can become a
how fast we can become a team by not
shortcut in the process is what it's
gonna be all about LeBron to your left a
the ad told me that you you spoke to
Lakers management and everybody about
how you think it's important to kind of
go through him two questions have you
ever done that before for another player
and why do you think it's important for
you to do that now yes I have actually
you know first a couple years in
Cleveland when I returned for the second
time you know I wanted the offerings
that go through Kyrie I just seen it the
talented level of talent that he had and
I wanted him to be able to run the show
be able to put us in position
having the basketball skills that Kyrie
had and I mean if you can go through
back to some of my transcripts I was
talking like I believe that you know
someday he could you know potentially be
a MVP in our league I just seen how
talented he was and so yes I've done it
before and in order for us we don't know
exactly what our offensive things that
we're gonna do defensively we're gonna
do we haven't got started yet like I
said we got a brand new coaching staff
we have brand new players coming to all
- a new system but we do know we all
know how great Anthony Davis is and if
we're not playing through Anthony Davis
why he's on the floor then it makes no
sense to have him on the floor but he's
that great and it doesn't mean like
every time down you know you know we
throw it to him and throw it to me throw
it to him but we have the ability to do
that and he's been very efficient in his
career he commands double teams and were
you able to attract to you know
defenders on one guy then you have the
numbers game now you got a four one
three on the back side so it opens up
for you know four other guys on the
floor including myself
LeBron over to your right thank you
you talked a lot of people around a
league this summer and there's
excitement because there's no clear-cut
favorite for the first time in a long
time can you recall a time of your
career where it felt like this going
into the year and how do you view you
know that the competitors or the
contenders are on the leak I'm not sure
Dave I don't know how to kind of say how
I feel or how I've seen I don't know you
know for me I think it's great with the
league has been able to do year after
year after the year we continue to be
the greatest sport in the world and we
put out the best product on the floor
every night to be competitive and and
played so not only our abilities but
also showcase talented our fans love
play with a lot of passion so in that
aspect I think it's great I think our
league is in a great position right now
Adam silver has done an unbelievable job
and every team has try to you know just
continue to get better and better and
better to help the league out ultimately
as far as me and as far as how I feel
you know my only goal is how I can
prepare myself every day to help this
team be as great as we
Camby and not shortcut the process
that's always been my goal every single
year and how ad and myself can lead
these guys and put them in position to
be successful every night not only from
a game aspect but from a practice aspect
as well will also be you know what we
want to accomplish
LeBron both the Lakers and Clippers made
moves to become title contenders this
summer and people here are really
excited what do you think la is gonna be
like between the Lakers and Clippers and
you guys one of the teams that were in
on Kauai what was your reaction what was
your reaction when Kauai and Paul George
went to the Clippers um well I think
it's um you know it's great for you know
everyone's talking about the big winners
of the summertime
is it the the Nets is it the Clippers of
the Lakers is actually Staples Center
Staples Center is the biggest winner of
the summer you know you if you're a fan
of the game of basketball you get an
opportunity to see the Clippers one
night and then you get an opportunity to
see the Lakers then he's got great shows
and great performers and artists and
everybody will come through Staples
Center all throughout the year Staples
Center as a place to be maybe even
Sierra Canyon can go there and play a
game just throwing that out there and
they have some some freshmen on a team
that's doing okay for himself as well
but no seriously um I think it's just
great I mean the city of Los Angeles
would be very proud of what's going on
not only with the Lakers and the
Clippers but also with the Rams and the
Dodgers and the Kings and USC and UCLA
and so on and so on if I missed you you
know I apologize but it's just it's a
great time to be a sports fan in the
city
LeBron do you take here do you take any
rankings are we do you take any extra
motivation after all that the team went
through last year and you still feel
like you have something to prove or show
to the LA Laker fans I'm very motivated
but I'm right now not in talking about
it moat I've been very quiet this summer
for a reason and my mother always taught
me I don't talk about it be about it man
so that's why I'm at
I think as a team and myself we need to
get the Lakers back to what they've been
accustomed to over a year so I'm excited
about that
LeBron you talk about the relationship
with with with ad and it seems like a
pretty there's a pretty deep bond there
but you know he's a free agent at the
end of this year does does that pending
decision has that influenced the way you
are thinking about that relationship and
going into this season to make sure that
he wants to stay here long term no of
course not
for me if you know me there's a couple
people that know me I'm a guy who lives
right now I live in the president and
you know what's happened in the past and
nothing you can do about that and you
can you have no idea what the future
holds you know so you know if you start
to think about the future then you will
miss out on a great opportunity that
might be right in front of your face and
and I think that's even more selfish so
for me having ad here right now and
having this ballclub here we're not even
gonna address that throughout the season
I bet ad will talk about it
but our goal is to get better every day
you know coach Vogel and the coaching
staff is gonna put us in the best
possible chance for us to win every
night and that's what it's all about
yeah are you planning on play for that
team you say next season next next year
are you planning on play for that team
USA Team USA I don't know I would love
to you know I have to I would like to
want to stay healthy as well that's most
important you know I was not happy about
you know how we did this summer I think
we're all a brotherhood and I know the
guys that was there they played you know
extremely hard they played extremely
well together they just fell a little
bit shorter than we what our
expectations are and and I applaud those
guys I didn't say anything obviously
whatever whatever playing but I applaud
every every one individually I was on
that team this summer including the
coaching staff and everybody but it's
not what we're accustomed to so you see
how I could do it throughout this season
and you know and I will you know address
that at some point you know hopefully
you have an opportunity have a
conversation with Coach pop and see what
his direction is you know going forward
with with Team USA but now always a blue
red white and blue that's for sure
LeBron to your right rob has talked
about a lot how he conference with you
and ad while the roster was being built
what was that process like and how has
that has that affected your relationship
or closing your relationship with Rob I
think it's not about what you know first
of all I think you know Rob and Kurt and
Linda and Jeanne and everybody upstairs
did a hell of a job this summer you know
from acquiring ad you know to acquiring
everyone that is a part of his team to
bring him back the guys that were free
agents last year bringing it back to the
roster they did a hell of a job and you
know bringing in the coaching staff
handpicking the coaching staff as they
did so you know throughout all
[Music]
throughout all the word that I want to
use is not for the threw out all the
bull that was narrated for our franchise
and narrated and and going towards Rob
and and the beautiful people that we
have upstairs
they just kept their their blinders on
and and just focus on what do they had
to do to help this franchise be as
competitive as they can be and they did
exactly that any and all so even
exceeded that so so you know I think
they did a hell of a job and you know
I'm happy to be a Laker appreciate it